[Musique]
report d'un certain nombre de crédits
qui peut être fait est là dessus la
région apporte sa garantie aux prêts
bancaires en lien avec mes pays france
c'est ce qu'à hauteur de garantie qui
demande à 90%
on veut venir à la fois évidemment
soulagé entreprises qui ont des crédits
pour des trésoreries tendues des prix
aussi leur permettre évidemment de
passer ce moment et elles ont besoin de
s'endetter à nouveau pour financer le
fond de roulement s'est évidemment leurs
bêtes technique actuel l'objectif c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de faillite donner le
moins possible il ya un dispositif
spécifique pour les très petites
entreprises des colloques et
individuelles avec un financement qui
aimante et y avait qu un fonds d'urgence
qui a été mis en place en lien avec le
temps que la région abonde massivement
et il a obligé aussi qu'on puisse les
aider à passer ce qu'on dit il
alors évidemment c'est alex de ne pas
être suffisant aussi le dire et c'est
pour cela que j'invite tous les acteurs
économiques à jouer leur rôle et surtout
à regarder l'ensemble des dispositifs
qui existent parce que chez mis bout à
bout quand on utilise ensemble mais on
peut espérer les nuits limitée de cette
crise dont on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
combien pas alba durée
[Musique]
j'ai pris la décision en tant que
président de la pierre et paul de
suspendre le paiement des loyers
là aussi provenir soulager les
trésoreries de la centaine de sociétés
johnny installé au sein de la pépinière
d'entreprises de prendre paul parce que
c'est une manière pour nous évidemment
de leur venir en aide
leur permettre de passer ce moment si
l'on peut le faire on va là aujourd'hui
une politique financière et
l'agglomération est pris n'est ni son dû
mais qui peut croire un autre exemple
l'autre fonds de prêts d'honneur
initiative quand on devine donc cette
visite la prime si la décision de
suspendre le remboursement des prêts
pour les entreprises qui en bénéficient
de l'appui de ce fonds elles sont
nombreuses